[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima welcome to
roses and rose a this is your
Bachelorette
Hannah Brown season finale part 1 recap
grab your glasses because I am joined by
a very special member of bachelor nation
jarred Haven is here everybody cheers
okay can you do the theme song with no I
can do anything anything three two one I
don't know what that means everybody I
hope you have your Rose day with you and
I want to thank by the way obvious wines
for sending me some simply wonderful
roses a just light and beautiful in
color like I like it thank you that's
what we're drinking tonight guys we want
your questions and comments we just
watched hannah break up with Peter we
just watched Hannah reveal that the
window was not one not two and we just
saw everything changed when Hannah's
family met both Tyler and Jed's so send
us your questions send us your comments
Jared and I are going through this
episode here we go Jared let's start on
here we go the rose ceremony so Hannah
sends Peter home very sad they are
crying they are crying together pretty
good this breakup was a bit of a
surprise for me we had seen Hannah say
before that everything changed in one
day for her that seemingly the fantasy
suites with Tyler how respectful he was
seemed to change who she was going to
pick I would guess between Tyler and
Peter because Jed was the first rose she
handed out what did you think here of
the goodbye and of Peter's emotional
response I thought it was sweet they
were both crying they both seemed really
sad that they were going I thought
Hannah was good in the moment too she
said that he did nothing wrong and
honestly I can't even give you an
explanation as to why I'm sending home
which is true because in this bachelor
world it's not that she didn't love him
it's not like she couldn't potentially
see a future with him but she saw a
better future with two other guys
there's nothing wrong with that it's so
hard when you get a breakup response
like that
I've never had to give them it's painful
because it's just there's nothing wrong
and yet it's not good enough
no but that's why so many times within
this bachelor world you hear I need
closure or I didn't get closure it's
because the moments like that because
they're really Peter didn't do anything
wrong
right she just liked to other guys more
that's kind of the name of the game
Peters in the car
he's crying he is saying that he's not
mad at Hannah he's saying he'll always
cherish these moments I have to say I
was a little surprised that he was so
quickly being so mature about it I
thought he'd be more like I can't
believe this what did you think was he
in shock what's going through your mind
in that moment when you're sent home
well I think for me when I was at home
it was just you're just stunned you know
because for two months your entire life
is surrounded around developing a
relationship with a girl you just met
and getting roses and so when you get
sent home it's kind of like this reality
check for a minute when you realize oh
my god okay it's over everything that
happened over the two months it just it
just ended so you're a little in shock
you're emotional it sucks because you're
not gonna be able to see like for Peter
he's not gonna be able to hold Hannah's
hand anymore be able to you know act
like her boyfriend like he's been doing
for two months Jerrod I need to ask you
a really real question in that moment
though if you're in one of those one of
the final group are you maybe thinking
okay I didn't find love here but maybe I
want to be the bachelor Bachelorette oh
my god be careful about my respond even
like you know like in the exit interview
right we're near in the car and you hear
it all the time where people who are in
the contention for The Bachelor where
they say like oh I'm ready to find love
you know it's not like they just said
that off the top of the head there you
know it's kind of like do you think
you're ready to find love as if like you
know if you're the guy you know would
you be ready to be the next Bachelor so
they kind of tee it up for everybody
they always ask questions like that they
were kind of teeing it up for Mike and
the men tell all this exit was teeing it
up for Peters I think Peter wants to be
the bachelor of course why not just
everybody watching The Bachelor
everybody wants to be the bachelor you
know everybody alright so then we get
Peter out on stage and this is Peter
live this is Peter not two months ago
Peters
out on stage he's not super cheerful I
don't think we saw him cry in the live
portion I like that you do like that why
yeah because it's there's been months
that have gone by hannah has obviously
moved on to another guy he's moved on to
whatever so I like that because there is
a I remember at my men my men tell all
I wasn't on the after final roses men
tell all where obviously was emotional
seeing Caitlyn but at all so there was
there was months in between you know so
I don't know I we I don't want to say
cuz I don't want to like be like oh say
that criticism say you know the people
who are like I'm still in love with them
always is like are you because you had
this sense of when you leave this
environment you know I think for me like
the first thing that came to my mind was
what the hell happened and how we roll
was that like how real was that my
feelings towards heard the entire
process and you know you end up finding
like oh it was very really you can
develop feelings very quickly but I
liked how Peter was like no we had a
wonderful time and it was great but I've
certainly moved on yeah I thought that
his response to it was solid he said
something like look you know it's hard
to really fall out of love with someone
but I've been working on it for two
months and you fall in love quickly I
mean sometimes people say that the
amount of time you're in a relationship
is the amount of time you need to
recover from it so I get that you can
recover quickly your comments are coming
in Chloe says Lauren you are so
channeling Hanna with this hair I know
ya know and the thing is I actually
critiqued the bun at that rose ceremony
I don't really love the bun and now look
what I've done the bun I like the bun I
like the top bun look yeah it's good
is Ashley doing top bun hair for the
wedding uh no I don't think so I just
thought she got her hair dyed it looks
gorgeous it does look great
yes okay Jared almost a newlywed here a
bachelor nation success story Hanna says
what did you think about Hannah's family
and Jed and I promise we're getting to
that I want to take a look at somebody
else's family though Peters family
stealing the show again let's watch
Peters parents in the audience and his
mom talking to him take a look your mom
and dad your brother
Barbara Peter and Jack are here
your mom's gone through a box of Kleenex
I know how he felt and it hasn't been
easy I know he has an amazing family -
could we be any more in love with Peters
parents and could they be any more in
love with each other I know it's pretty
fantastic especially the parents you
don't really see it a lot unless you're
at hometowns but the parents go through
a lot with this experience because it's
their child on TV being scrutinized and
judged by millions of people and then
going through this emotional process
where like they're the ones who kind of
pick up the pieces after they come back
and so it was it was nice to see a
parent just kind of crying because I
know for a fact if my mom was there she
would be doing the exact same thing just
overwhelmed you know what is hometown
they said he no he's their son they
wanted to be so happy we always play a
little drinking game at roses and Rose a
drink responsibly but tonight we're just
gonna cheers for every moment we
freaking loved in this finale and I
loved Peters parents cheers guys Peter's
parents mm-hmm
Pete's parents Pete's parents will just
show this little b-roll of oh my god as
they went into break I felt that they
were the true love story of the episode
yeah that's a door wait for it wait for
it mom's gonna go in and she's going to
caress dad's face that's Peter Rock and
the facial hair still he started the
facial here in the tan and grease I
support the stubble on Peter cuz he's
got a bit of a baby face oh yeah I love
it yeah it was you're rocking some
facial area yeah yeah so I was actually
Cohen for like the Dean look a little
bit I shaved down the beard and grew and
my I left my mustache a little bit
longer you know I'm not doing it for the
wedding but you know Dean's had a little
impact on me anyway moving forward I
like the facial hair on Peter it reminds
me of when Nick started growing facial
hair and everything changed and
everything changed right
all of a sudden Nick grew a beard and he
was the bachelor and so I could this
happen for Peter you grew a beard he
became the bachelor maybe he was trying
to learn from the best you know do you
guys think Peter will be bachelor now
that he's definitely not the guy for
Hannah now let us know Oh No
oh let us know in the comments what you
guys think I don't I don't I don't think
it's gonna be better not that he want to
make a great bachelor why not because
if I don't know she's either picking Jed
or Tyler and from this episode it did
look like who the hell knows what's
gonna happen but if Tyler if Tyler does
get picked how was that man not the
bachelor he's the most popular
contestant I think I've ever seen in the
history of the show
during the iteration of the show yeah
his popularity has been insane I took
woman transcribing his speeches weekly
I've made multiple gifts if Tyler seen a
Tyler T all available on my Twitter page
I love you for saying that it's a tough
call because I do know that you know the
decisions that are made by the people
actually work on the show probably have
a lot to do with like they've gotten to
know these people at this point and we
don't know like I don't know there could
be some story that Peter has that we
don't know or a story that Tyler has or
or how they are to work with or Mike
yeah I mean well they showed Mike in
paradise so that's gonna be I mean we'll
see how it was the bachelor to Paradise
know exactly it all depends on what he
does down there I know and we have
learned that we will not find out the
bachelor this week we won't find out the
bachelor yet I think probably until
paradise starts airing we won't find out
I don't think the bachelor like week
four or five paradise anyway well it's
obviously I've been in the world yeah
being on paradise for a couple of those
years you see like the timeline you know
well I'm with you Tyler see incredibly
popular we will have to see and we're
gonna get into this but it's interesting
to me that you said don't know what's
gonna happen after tonight it's been
hard to avoid rumors or rumors of
spoilers Hanna even acknowledged it at
the end of this episode you guys she
said I know there are a lot of rumors
out there they will all be addressed
tomorrow night Tuesday night on the
second part of the live finale but if I
hadn't heard any of that I have to say
watching tonight's episode I would be
sitting there thinking how could you not
pick Tyler he's the most quote
respectful me and you've ever been with
your family loved him the only thing I
can think is that Hanna did say Jed's
the guy who she's seen herself with from
the beginning he has that kind of
original connection to her so that can
be powerful yeah I think Jed is the
person that she loves more but Tyler's
probably the guy that she feels like she
should you know and she probably has
feelings for him of course obviously she
does said she's falling in love with him
but I think that she just
is in love with yet and has been for
quite some time and so I don't know yeah
quite some time he was the only one she
had said I'm falling no were you to
Hunger Games fan says did you guys think
there was still something between Hannah
and Peter I definitely sense the
chemistry remember she said ten out of
ten and should we play this bite right
now you know what we'll wait one second
but here we go Hannah comes out she
talks to Peter by the way guys I thought
Hannah looked gorgeous please leave your
prints on her outfit loved the ponytail
yeah she looks great I'm a mature look
for Hannah which I loved she tells him
you know it really is still tough to say
what went wrong but then she says this
Hannah worried she would let go of the
perfect guy take a listen and I think I
was scared I was letting go of the
perfect guy
[Applause]
cheers to that audience member who
yelled you did again their voice heard
Hannah had often called Peter this kind
of Kendall you know he's a pilot he's
got this great family
and we also found out even more about
Hannon Peters chemistry and the windmill
moment yeah look at this major reveal
from tonight's I will say I am I was a
little dishonest about something oh no I
mean since it's out there and you know I
did say there was something that Peter
and I did twice it was actually four
times
[Applause]
cheers to four times Jared wears
definitely cheers four times I mean
honestly
as a man yes good for you Peter
damn four times you gotta wonder wow she
really had to feel strongly about the
other guys to let four times go I know I
feel bad because I like it ah whoever
she picks tomorrow like hypothetically
what if she does pick Tyler you know in
like the night before she's like yeah by
the way I had sex with Peter four times
you know what Oh God
I don't know I mean Oh interesting well
I gotta say I think we're all assuming
she picks Jed at this point okay no I
was just gonna say especially after that
Oh like because well think about it like
any more wine for this chair well think
about like Tyler's whole thing is how
respectable he's been he's been super
respectful right right don't you think
it would be kind of Oh maybe a hint of
disrespect if like the night before they
announced their engagement together
she's like by the way I lied Peter and I
didn't have sex twice
we had sex four times it would be like
oh it's so interesting Jared I didn't
think about that
you know her announcing an engagement
really to either of them tomorrow and
the night before revealed for time yeah
I loved it was just I think Hannah's
been incredible Bachelorette she's been
able to articulate herself she hasn't
taken any crap she's really been able to
go after what she wants right and so
even when when she said like we did it
twice in the windmill loved it because
there was such like an emotional moment
where she was like screw you Luke you
know not yeah you're not ashamed of
myself yeah you don't want me to have
sex I had sex twice in a windmill and
like it was such a good moment where
tonight it just seemed a little forced
right where she was like by the way
before we end things I have to say one
more thing and it's like okay wonder
what she's gonna say and she's like I
lied we don't have sex we had sex four
times it's like a funny moment but I was
like huh interesting because that makes
me believe that I don't know what the
hell I believe does that make you
believe she could be like single
tomorrow she doesn't have anybody to
worry about hurting her feelings
it's an interesting point Jerry don't
you think like whoever she would pick
like in any bachelor bachelorette they
want to protect whoever they picked
right because it's really tough
the person that did get chosen because
then they have to go back and watch her
fall for so many other people and it's
it's a tough roller coaster ride and so
a lot of the leads you don't want to do
whatever they can to make their
significant other feel better I don't
know if that was cheers to your theory
Jared it's a very good it's like would
anybody who's engaged say that whether
you're engaged whether you're man woman
whatever yeah you probably if you're
about to announce their engagements the
eve of announcing your engagement you
wouldn't feel great about your
significant other saying I slept with
this person X times the night before in
front of me and it's in the past that
it's over but like did you need to
clarify it interesting you need to give
like that much specific I was always
like is she trying to give Peter like an
extra boost because she thinks he's such
a good guy and she let him go I mean I
mean honestly she did no matter what
happens like four times I mean we're
getting a lot of comments in about the
four times yeah Brittany said how does
she mention four times and still end up
with someone else
a lot of you loving Peters parents and
Amanda says why do you think they didn't
talk about the Peter girlfriend
situation Amanda a very interesting
point absolute thing yeah because
honestly I did this podcast with one
Chris Harrison and he said that that was
probably gonna come up the ex-girlfriend
thing so I have to be honest I'm
wondering is this something to do with
Peter being potentially in the running
for bachelor do we want to make sure
that he's protected that was what was on
my mind yeah that's actually a good
question because my mind would assume if
he isn't running for the bachelor they
would want any baggage to go away which
would mean to address it as soon as
possible and then hopefully let it die
and it hasn't been addressed and
honestly I had to be fair at the end of
the day I don't think it's a big deal I
never thought it was a big deal I think
I mean I don't know the particulars all
I know is that apparently from the
rumors is that they broke up in December
and he ended it without any closure and
he probably did it for the show I'm not
saying that's the right thing to do it's
not but he from personal experience you
don't know if you're on the show till
February so he absolutely broke up with
her before he knew he's on the show
perhaps even before
he was in the running for the show I
don't know I figured we were gonna find
out tonight we didn't so who the hell
knows it did seem the thing is it's
certainly not along the lines of the JED
rumors it did seem like it would have
been something fairly easy to address to
close the book on but who knows then you
run the risk of it becoming he-said
she-said on and on and on
makes me feel like he's more guilty
interested because of it like if it's
not that bad just address it but it
makes me think that maybe maybe he
didn't do something wrong and he got a
phone call like in October and and
producers are like hey you're single and
he's like yeah speaking of phone calls
can the lesson from both Peter and Jed
be this you guys call the person when
you break up with them before you go on
a reality show give them a ring an FYI
yeah but to be fair Peter did break up
with her before like that is a huge
difference and I'm not saying what it
was right but that is a no but here's my
only thing I think if you call the
person if you give them a heads up
you're just you're covering your own
bases yeah I mean we did eat
Entertainment Tonight interviewed this
woman who says she's Peters
ex-girlfriend according to her she
watched he knew she watched the show and
he took her to the bachelor mansion
which he lives near so you know this is
her story but allegedly she he knew she
watched the show subdued sure hey I'm
gonna be on the show I know that's bad I
did that with with my ex-girlfriend so
you gave it a heads up oh I had to and
it worked out perfectly because I didn't
know if she watched the show but she
informed me that she was currently
watching Cristal season which was the
season if she would have seen young so
thank God yeah I informed her because oh
if she would have saw me come out of
limo and tell her oh my god just give a
heads-up just don't be here I'd be dead
you would not be getting married soon
oh so many comments coming in from you
guys we love it - I love that water says
we do love water that the true love
story this season has been Hanna with
herself and she's loved it I agree we
love Hanna amanda says Peter situation
and jed's are different I agree they're
different I also think give somebody a
phone call okay
moving forward guys let's get back to
our hashtag respectful King
see so now Hannah's family is in Greece
although we knew Hannah's parents by the
way who were those other three people
were they ever we don't know who they
were
did she have siblings I'm assuming that
was my assumption I don't think we ever
got their names I just wanted to know
they were there every time but we didn't
hear from them I I don't know
but Tyler talks to Hannah's mom talks
Anna's dad what did you think overall of
Tyler on the date with Hannah's family
oh he was great
killed it killed it actually I mean
there's really not even much more to say
about it killed it with the parents was
very direct told me she's looking at him
like I love you oh yeah please please be
my son-in-law oh yeah I mean he is a
good-looking man he's very old school
handsome and I think that's why he's old
Hollywood handsome like he could be the
good analogy that I make because Ashley
was obsessed with John F Kennedy jr.
yeah reminds me very much of like a John
F Kennedy jr. look where it's like old
school just very handsome and yeah I
mean wow I'm really hyping up Tyler see
I am I am a contrarian at heart though
okay and Tyler's awesome very
respectable seems like a great guy I
will say there's only one thing that
bothers me a little bit about Tyler see
like there's just a lot of lines there's
a lot of what's your perfect you're
awesome and it's like oh god please
please don't say that one more time
let's play it let's take a listen to
Tyler talking to Hannah's dad you know I
want her to leave my family have faith
the way she's done so far on this trip
and to be that strong woman as she is I
don't have any second-guessing or any
doubt about me and her at all so do you
mean lines like that these like kind of
speeches that he makes do you believe
them oh I believe them I think just like
any guy right we always kind of hype it
up and so but I think from just watching
it the entire season it's like yes I get
it Hannah's perfect you know it's not a
bad thing I'm not criticizing no here's
what's interesting to me Jared everybody
come out to be like are you criticizing
Tyler see cuz I swear to god Jared it's
like no I love how your everybody is a
Boston accent yeah it's like everybody
from your dad's gonna critique you well
why not when I get defensive and realize
I have to like fight back I get a little
girl
a little tough I'm shaking Rosie how
tough can I possibly be cheers - Tyler
sees lines whether we like them or not
everybody please drink responsibly yes
please drink responsibly I did not drink
for that I okay
I'm wondering if there's a difference in
perspective here because I actually have
been more man on the stuff Peter said
because Peter only talked about his
feelings and only and all he's usually
said was I've never felt this intensely
as I mean like I do for Hannah I've
never had feelings like this versus I
feel like Tyler talks about Hannah and
the things he likes about her and it's
more interesting to me yeah I agree I
think a lot of times what the show does
too is a lot of the contestants talk in
very vague terms and when I wish the
show would I don't know if it's a
contestants for the show but I wish they
could showcase more of like the specific
intimate moments cuz like there's a
moment on Becca coupe season that I'll
never forget that Garrett he just said
randomly a 90 M he's like I love the way
she says beg he just said that it was
like such a real moment it wasn't like
she's amazing I can see a future with
her you know I want to propose I love
her I'm falling in love with her it was
just like I love the way she says beg
and like when he said it you could just
tell that oh my god he just he loves
that and it was like such a moment that
you're like wow that's that's when I
need more of you know and so I agree
Tyler's far more better at that than
Peter is interesting I do be st. Peter
Oh youth Tyler make a better bachelor
well okay guys don't come after Jared
he's supporting Tyler comment saying
Tyler can do no wrong shame on you Jared
I was waiting for that he's perfect no
wrong here's the thing
yeah Rizzi says Tyler remains
unproblematic a king I mean I keep
saying Tyler sees scandal-free I hope
that it stays that way and it's so
interesting you guys are bringing in a
lot of comparisons like our dove says he
reminds you of Johnny Cash I've heard so
many JFK jr. Paul Newman people say
Patrick Swayze
generic old-school Hollywood hotness
he's I know oh yeah Dean a little bit I
no um D de winter says thoughts that
maybe Hannah and Peter if she's single
could give it another go he seemed done
tonight Peter yeah I think I think
they're both done I think they're both
ready to go their separate ways the door
has closed yeah of course that's what
happens sometimes breakers especially
like Hannah moved on with another guy
whoever the hell that is
two other guys actually and then you
know Peter I'm sure has watched back the
season has gotten a new perspective on
things cuz what your tongue like anybody
in a relationship right once you're out
of the relationship and can take a step
back and look at it you get a new
perspective on it and once you've hit
four times can it get any better maybe
you've just peaked yeah yeah yeah you've
peaked
it's like George walking out of the of
the interview when he's just at his
house I am I always am all right guys
keep your comments coming in misty
Schwartz says are we going to talk about
the ex-girlfriend drama tomorrow I'm
guessing you mean with Jed Chris
Harrison told me in our interview that
they were going to but that didn't
happen with Peter but with Jed I feel
like you can't ignore it that he also
just recognized misty Schwartz wooden
great name what up girl misty cased
warts yeah miss Kay Swartz I hope that's
not just your user name and that's
actually her name because that's awesome
yeah yeah they have to address the JED
stuff because we were talking about
before I am all for due process and I am
all for you know evidence so I would
love to hear Jed's side of it having
said that it's been what two months
since the story has ran it's kind of
hard for me it would take a lot for me
to believe jet at this point if he does
come out tomorrow and say that whole
thing is fabricated and she is lying and
just trying to make a name for herself
yeah I don't know cuz now I'm at the
point where like it's been two months of
my life where it's just jet had a
girlfriend and so and he never defended
him something and I understand a little
gala tea part of it in certain cases but
this is an illegal issue to my knowledge
unless he's suing her for defamation
behind right no I mean I think probably
the argument that a lot of people would
make her guess is just that he's kind of
perhaps
you know advised by the show you've got
to address this with us on camera I mean
that's what I would guess I don't know
yeah but I mean to not come out at all
and say hey I'm innocent I'm gonna talk
about it on after the final rose but I
am you're saying he could have just said
simply I'm innocent because he did post
on Instagram and was a little vague and
said I'm gonna speak when I can I know
you're saying but just to say this isn't
true yeah in the fact that I think we
think I also think at this point one of
his friends or his family who are not
bound by any contract would have come
forward and said this is crazy yeah this
is insane yeah and so yeah I think all
he can do at this point is come out own
things apologize say I've learned and
grown like if you just own it completely
to me you know a lot of people said that
Luke pee was a a lot of people use the
word bullied at the men tell all
I don't know I don't think that Luke pee
owned everything at the tell-all I don't
I think if you come out and owned
everything and apologized and not
continued to make it appear that he
doesn't think women are on an equal
mental plane as men then America would
have said hey you're a 24 year old maybe
you had a lot to learn maybe you had to
meet some different types of people and
grow and would have forgiven him and
move forward but he didn't do that no he
didn't do that but I also think those
two things aren't mutually exclusive I'm
not going to use the term bullied but I
really I thought it was a poor showing
by a lot of DJ yeah just because to pile
on like that the name-calling is never
okay with me yeah the Psychopaths thing
the Psychopaths thing I wasn't down with
and then even Mike at some point was
like your future wife is gonna be a
prisoner of you and it's like guys do we
really do we really have to just like
keep going with this and then the
audience members are like clapping and
like it's like I get it guys Luke P has
some issues and he needs to just not be
a part of the Batchelor franchise for a
while and do some self-reflecting but do
we like do we really need no policies
very nice but do we need him to say f
off I was shocked when I yeah it's like
come on guys well I know so the thing is
I mean a lot of people already had these
feelings about Luke P they didn't need
to convince us that he had some growing
to do with their words but you know what
I don't know I get I we were witnessing
I think pent-up frustration on their
part
perhaps maybe and that that has to be
fast justifying it
Lizzie Winchester saying do you think
Hannah will pull a Jason I go after so
dump Jed for Tyler and then go with the
other guy yeah if she's with Jed dump
Jed go Tyler if she's that's not gonna
happen
you don't think so why not because I am
I mean it's not like the difference with
Jason was Jason picked was it Melissa
he's with Molly now yeah but so Jason
picked someone and then a month later or
whatever it was like I'm having regrets
and I I'm gonna break up with you and go
after my number two this is different
because Hanna picked Jed wanted to stay
with you presumably presumably we don't
know and then found out this crap and it
was like we'll screw you it's not like I
should have picked Tyler it was like or
like you know what I see you're saying
not an air on her part no it was because
of something else because an outside
factor she would go back after Tyler I
got because of her not because her
feelings are stronger for Tyler yeah
very good point okay that's all we can
do it there you know rose and Rose a
tomorrow tomorrow night oh man so what
are you gonna talk about we're already
talking about tomorrow night so many
comments coming in from you guys the
pointers say Lauren will you be
disappointed if Hanna ends up single no
I won't Hanna's awesome she's very
independent girl go get yours fine
she'll be an icon an icon okay let's
talk a little bit about a Jed meeting
Luke's fam or Jen meeting Hannah's
family and then we're gonna wrap up here
because wow wow wow what a moment and
Hanna Doherty asks what we thought of
that Hanna we're gonna get into it so
Jed meets Hannah's family now and Jed
conversation with her dad goes a little
differently than Tyler's take a look you
know at this point my most major
accomplishment is that I signed a deal
with it
dog food company light their jingle and
that's been like my first real like
breakthrough else I go this is like the
start of something you know I'm just
trying to look out for her guy don't say
that you just say music is going well
I'm making a living off of it I'm
supporting myself things are getting
better but when he said signed I was
like oh wow did it Jed sign it some sort
of record label field then he was like a
dog jingle and there's nothing wrong
with that at all we're not dismissing or
disrespecting it what we're saying is
you should not tell the parent of your
future wife hopefully that that is your
biggest accomplishment in music and then
say music is what I'm working towards
I thought he certainly could have
avoided this whole situation if he would
have said my biggest accomplishment so
far is meeting and falling for and
building a relationship with your
daughter that's it just avoid that whole
dog food commercial jingle moment but
you know what cheers to a great moment
in television and the dog food
commercial don't go poor Jed well not
Porges you could have offered me a
million dollars I never would have
guessed that was what he was going to
say no ah anything anything but that
thought he would say I recorded an EP or
like yeah I saw I just released an album
I thought like you said I thought he's
gonna say sign with a small label or
something a dog jingle no and and I
loved Hannah's daddy I'm just trying to
look out for this whole meeting with the
parents I mean it went so poorly and
it's also so interesting because I feel
like Hannah got a lot of criticism for
ignoring red flags with Luke and I think
now honestly as much as we love her and
I love her I think people will critique
her for ignoring a parent red flags with
Jed her meeting his family did not go
well now him meeting her family did not
go well and those are important
interactions yes yeah it's like yes it's
hard though I mean what is you have to
prioritize to do you go with your like
if your gut is telling you one person
and your parents are telling you another
what do you go with I think that Jed was
saying some really dangerous and quite
frankly immature
things to Hana during this date because
she had to leave at one point and by the
way don't drink for all of the silence
from Hannah's mom and dad their silence
and their look score everything you know
a drink for his parents we love Hannah's
parents we Stan Hannah and we stand
Hannah's mama that we do but he goes out
to her and he says look you know we know
what we have and I'm like I don't I'm
never a supporter of this it's you and
me against the world thing and in this
case he was kind of saying we know what
we have and sort of acting like maybe
her parents are being too judgmental
like I don't want it to be you and me
against the world I want it to be you
and me experiencing the world together
and I think that Hannah's parents were
just being really sensible and they were
worried about you know what their
daughter's future would be like totally
on the one hand I'm not here to crush
Jed's dreams on the other hand parents
want to protect their kids and that's
what their concern was I know he could
have said some sort of line in saying
like I will do whatever it you know
needs to be done in order to support and
you know be with my wife right we'd be
okay and instead of just being like
musics my thing and we're gonna go with
it right and what's interesting was like
the whole People magazine thing comes
back in my head it's like what the girls
only here for music now because this
whole thing is like I'm here for music
and like I love Hannah but she's got to
fit into my world
I was shocked we didn't gonna get our
song with the parents I feel we're gonna
get one more performance before the
season is over it's just my guess based
on the ratio the percentage and
statistics have you ever seen just
friends with the relateed Dinkelman yeah
well somebody tweeted yeah because he's
always singing and he makes us you know
make songs about women I'm sorry we got
jeered and Lauren you're both so
sensible high five my friend let's drink
yeah we love being sensible
I love being sensible I don't even know
for being that sensible we're getting
some love for you Ken says yard Congrats
on your wedding happy for you and Ashley
yeah thank you so much appreciate it
getting married so soon first ha Beth
Butler says it's someone with a master's
degree in music I cannot say I'm
impressed with its music yeah nobody is
I think he's getting a lot of hate to
just because of the ex-girlfriend thing
like and I don't want to throw hate his
way I mean I think sometimes people get
like I
this doesn't need to be about hate I
don't hate jet I don't know Jed
am i critical of Jed on a reality show
yeah you know cuz that's what he chose
to do go beyond this reality show no
I'll talk about it I know we all signed
up for it like even you know Ashley and
I sometimes have a difficult time with a
lot of people judging us and accusing
things of us and and it's hard but at
the end of the day you know we did sign
up for it I wish people were nicer right
be the mean comments like yeah anything
we're saying right now we're saying kind
of like light hearted and we're percent
you know we're talking great things
about the only thing we're really
criticizing is Jed but that's also
because we're thinking he tried to lie
manipulate Hanna yeah or like I don't
I'm just I wish I hope Jed's open and
honest tomorrow night about everything
because I just want to know listen did
you go home with the girlfriend and then
you ended up falling in love with Hanna
and now you're great going on with a
girlfriend and you screwed up he made a
mistake and you thought it was fake but
it's actually real then say it you know
don't be afraid to say that yes because
he has to he has to he has to own
everything I always say the biggest
mistake people make in reality
television is not just owning their
actions but Jared I also say it's the
same thing with Jed according to this
girl according to her he went on the
show in a relationship with her and
never called her after he came back is a
person a car you can't pick up the phone
I mean I didn't know what if I was Jed
though leaving the show what do you do
like how do you call your ex well it's
about owning it I guess right I mean I
yeah I'm curious if Hanna knew because
we're all assuming this is true I mean
maybe it's not but like I'm curious when
Hanna found out did she find out from
the people article did she find out from
him I'm fascinated to know all these
things I this is kind of harkening back
to the re and Becca finale for me where
so much happened afterwards that like we
got new there there was I will admit
there was a promo in the beginning of
this episode where it it looked like
maybe it was something that had been
filmed more recently to me of just Hanna
talking and I'm like are we gonna get
additional footage I'm dying to watch
tomorrow and I don't know if I've ever
anticipated an AFR more
kate says jared you're amazing Tatum
says he should bring the guitar to the
final rose ceremony I want to address
one thing and very quickly we won't even
play the SOT but did
and want a drink for Hannah's mom again
Hannah said to her well how do you feel
about jet and I together and Hannah's
mom said quote well he has qualities you
know it's just that close to qualities
they could be good he has qualities if
my mom like I had a hometown with
Caitlin and she said well she has
qualities yeah it's like mom be nice
well then conversely she said of Tyler
he's on his own like he's in a league of
his own Hannah's mom fell for Tyler we
can't agree I think Hannah's dad fell
for Tyler Tyler is the guy that you want
to bring home to mom you know like he's
good-looking he's he's handsome he's
respect yes he's just he's got it all
going you know and then we get these
final moments with Hannah and Tyler
final final moments with Hannah and Jed
very different vibes hannah is saying if
Tyler what you're just saying he's the
kind of guy you want to introduce as
your husband Hannah and Jed not so much
Jed saying he's feeling anxious Hannah
literally getting sick on a boat and
it's gonna be so interesting to see how
it all goes tomorrow night I want to
address one thing yeah
Heather Lange says did anyone else
noticed that no one asked for the dad's
permission that was missing from tonight
I kind of forgot that we didn't have a
can I have the permission to marry your
daughter moment I would imagine it was
on the cutting room floor but we
certainly didn't see it oh yeah that is
interesting that makes me think that
there is no proposal yeah I didn't think
about that why would they not show that
I don't know I do not know because
there's always they always ask unless
unless what if Hannah's dad said no to
Jed so why wouldn't we see that I'm
baffled yeah I don't same why they're
gonna say that unless like tomorrow
comes and one of the guys remember how
been called Lauren's dad maybe it's
something like that we're like it's a
nice moment where they call the dad Jed
brights a jingle writes a jingle and
then has the dad on speakerphone plays
the jingo he says no and just like I'm
still gonna propose my daughter's family
like that you he's like yeah hey I could
sure my future dad-in-law father-in-law
dad
like this is a jingle that I sold to the
dog food
poor Jedi I honestly I really hope the
best for Jedi I do because I know he's
getting a lot of criticism and he but at
the end of the day if he I had if he did
go on I mean there's no beating around
the bush he'd tried to like lie his way
through this entire thing if it's true
that's a hard thing for me to to defend
in anyway most extra worse is that at
first he was getting the praise for
being the guy who owned coming on the
show for his career because he said that
- yeah and then it turns out oh wait
there was allegedly another possible
layer of a lie I don't know and so it's
just really nerve racking out I know I
feel bad I feel bad for everybody
involved
look unless unless you pick Tyler and
then everything's fine but if she picks
Jed you know what that I feel bad I feel
bad for Hanna I feel bad for there is a
part of me that feels bad for Jed how
can you not just as a human being
wait he's gonna have to go through
tomorrow night percent feel bad for
Tyler forgetting is heartbroken if he
doesn't end up with her no I think
Tyler's okay I think Tyler's gonna be
just a gram I think Tyler's fine let me
ask you this year and as we wrap up here
a final question do you because a lot of
you have been writing in and saying or
do you guys do you want Hannah to pick
Jed you want her to pick Tyler who do
you think she will pick now are you such
a Tyler fan that like you want him to be
the bachelor so you don't want Hannah to
pick him cuz that's kind of where I
might personally be no I'd rather have
Hannah pick him just be just be happy
just for Hannah to be happy also sew it
hand it isn't have to go through the
whole Jed situation because if they are
together or if they were together and
still together engaged
boyfriend-girlfriend broken up I have no
idea there's just gonna be a lot yeah
there's gonna be a lot of conversations
about it obviously there needs to be
right but if she picks Tyler then she
can avoid all those conversations and
move forward without it and just leave
kind of like Jed you're great but you
need to handle this yourself because you
kind of brought it upon yourself alright
just going through a couple of you
guys's comments one last time here again
we're left for Jared and we love them to
follow thank you social if you don't
already
yeah it's Jared he be edgy
Haven just like John Paul Jones Chelsea
says what about Tyler's dance education
yes a very good point I loved that he
took ballet I think college athletes do
that a lot like Cubs yeah we knew we
danced I don't know if we knew we did
ballet but we'll support it
and you guys tomorrow night on ABC live
part 2 the final final episode of Hannah
Brown season of The Bachelorette
you know what I don't mind if she ends
up with jet without jet with Tyler
without Tyler because Hannah has been
one of my favorite bachelorettes of all
time and I think she's gonna be fine
with or without somebody so Hannah
cheers to Hannah and yeah tomorrow it's
just a big night for everybody involved
like the final three it's such a big
night tomorrow night because you have
Tyler and his huge popularity like we
talked about before might be the most
beloved Bachelorette contestant in the
history of the show I mean taking
yourself out of the running there that's
fine I'm fine
I'm confident with who I am but at the
end of the day like Tyler C is just like
I remember how much like Dean like Dean
was obsessed over on The Bachelorette
right and Peter Krause yeah he's almost
the same level Rachael Lindsey season
yeah and it's just like doesn't even
compare I feel like I feel like Tyler's
kind of like bumped it up to notch and
then you have Jed with all the stuff
he's going through with the
ex-girlfriend and the People magazine
article and his music and like it's just
and so he has so much on the line cuz he
has to explain everything and then you
have Hannah who's picking from one of
these two guys and she's gonna announce
her engagement or not engagement
tomorrow night is she single if she's
with somebody because if she's single
like think about how much love hannah
has gone well deserved by the way she's
been awesome she's been a great
Bachelorette she's gotten so much love
if she comes out of this single tomorrow
night is it really out of the realm of
possibility she's Bachelorette again
next year
whoa Jared whoa cheers to another theory
I would support it I mean how can you
not especially if she does pick Jed and
that whole thing that whole situation
now came out and she broke up with him
she's a queen I mean she's already a
queen but now she's like it's like that
girl deserves another shot she does I
gotta say I don't okay I do wonder
sometimes
we got your theories out I'm with you
but I do going to clear your eyes I get
in the place of if you've been on the
show already is it hard for you to do it
again because you know so much about how
it works oh yeah I remember my second
season of paradise you just have like a
different perspective on things but
hannah is very genuine I think she could
do it Jared I love your theories very
quickly we are so excited for you and
Ashley to get married like a helmet will
you guys be like are you like taking
phones at the wedding or will be we get
to see it on social what's the plan
that's a great question to which I don't
know the full extent of we know that
we're gonna make as an announcement at
the ceremony that we don't want any
phones because we just really want that
to be a and you know we have a
photographer and a videographer so of
course they'll be footage taken from
there but we just really want that kind
of like I want especially that moment I
just want everybody to like focus yeah
you know be in it okay well I don't know
because you know it's tough and you're
you know it's 2019 everybody has their
phone I don't think we want you know
it's kind of like we're on stage like no
flash photography people okay
but of course we will be releasing some
sort of footage from the wedding sir how
people can be can see it of course we
love you guys we're so happy for you
thank you and Jared thank you for being
here guys we will be back live tomorrow
night again right after the finale wraps
here in the studio to talk it all
through a roses and Rose a thank you
guys so much for watching and continue
to tweet Jared and I your thoughts and
let's hear thanks guys
bye Mike
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you